Bonjour à tous, aujourd’hui dans ScienceClic,
la théorie des cordes.
Notre univers contient de la matière,
qui,lorsqu'on zoome suffisamment,est formée de particules.
Il en existe différents types :
les électrons,les quarks, ou encore les neutrinos.
Les particules se déplacent dans l’univers,
et peuvent interagir ens’échangeant d’autresparticules.
La force électromagnétique par exemple,
est véhiculée par l’échange de photons.
Toutes ces différentes particules
constituentce qu’on appelle le “modèle standard”.
C’est à ce jour notre description
mathématiquela plus précise du monde quantique.
On y trouve deux grandescatégories de particules :
les “fermions”, qui constituent la matière notamment,
et les “bosons”, qui contribuentà décrire les interactions.
A première vue,
on pourrait penserqu’il s’agit de LA théorie ultime,
que le modèle standard permet de tout décrire.
Mais malheureusement,
il existeune autre interaction quiéchappe à ce modèle :
la gravitation.
A grande échelle,
on sait décrire lagravitation par la relativité générale.
Les astres courbent l’espace-temps,ce qui attire les autres astres.
Comme pour les autres types d’interactions,
on s’attendrait à ce que la courbure del’espace-temps
soit composée à l’échellequantique de petites particules,
des quanta decourbure d’espace-temps, appelés “gravitons”.
Mais lorsqu’on essaie d’inclurele graviton au modèle standard,
les calculs donnent des résultats absurdes,
avec des valeurs infinies auxquellesil est impossiblede remédier
Rien à faire,
on ne parvient pas à décrirela gravité à l’échelle quantique...
C’est pour résoudre ce problème, que les physiciens
recherchent depuis plus d'un demi-siècle de nouvelles théories.
Dans cette vidéo,nous allons construire ensemble
l’une des approches les plus prometteuses…
la théorie des cordes.
L'idée de base est plutôt simple.
Dans le modèle standard, les particules
sontdécrites comme des petits points, sans dimension.
Eton admet que ces points n’ontpas tous lesmêmes propriétés
pour expliquer qu’il existedifférents types de particules.
En théorie des cordes,
on va supposerque ceci n’est qu’une approximation,
et qu'en réalité si l’on zoome sur les particules,
elles sont toutes formées d’un même objet,
unepetite corde, parfois ouverte, parfois fermée.
Ces petites cordes possèdent une tension,
commede minuscules élastiques, et elles peuvent vibrer.
Une corde de guitare peut vibrer
selondifférents modes, des “harmoniques”.
De même,
les petites cordes peuventvibrer de différentes façons :
une vague,
deux vagues,
trois vagues,
et ainsi de suite…
Et chaque façon de vibrer
se comporte, à notreéchelle, comme une particule différente.
Lorsqu’on réalise les calculs, on découvre notamment
quecertaines cordesse comportent comme des photons,
et mieuxencore, certaines comme des gravitons.
En partant du seul principe que les particules
sont de toutes petites cordes avec une tension,
on explique déjà pourquoi il existedifférents types de particules.
Et on prédit naturellementl’existence du graviton,
décrivant la gravité à l’échelle quantique.
On souhaite désormais
comprendre la façondont ces cordes évoluent dansl’univers.
Pour cela,
on va reprendre lesprincipes de nos modèles actuels…
Imaginons qu’on lance un électron sur une cible.
L’électron se propage comme uneonde, et lorsqu’il atteint la cible,
on ne peut pas prédire à l’avance laposition où il va se matérialiser.
A l'échelle des particules,
une même expérience peut donnerplusieurs résultats différents.
On peut simplement prédire
la probabilitéd’observer tel ou tel résultat,
et l’objectif de la Physique, à cette
échelle, est de déterminer ces probabilités.
L’approche mathématique
pour déterminerla probabilité d’observer un résultat
revient à considérer
tous les scénarios possiblesqui mènent à ce résultat,
en même temps.
On additionne toutes les trajectoires,
mais également toutes les interactions possibles :
par exemple,
un électron peut émettre un photonpuis le réabsorber,
ou deux photons, voire trois.
Dans tous les scénarios qu’on comptabilise,
on décide manuellement
d’autorisertels ou tels types d‘interactions,
pour reproduire ce qu’on observe dans la réalité.
Et en additionnant
tous ces scénarioson obtient la probabilité voulue.
En théorie des cordes, l’approche est la même,
mais les particules ne sontplusdes points… ce sont des cordes.
Un point trace une trajectoire au cours du temps,
mais une corde trace une surface.
Et pour décrire l’évolution d’une corde,
defaçon probabiliste, comme en physique quantique,
on va considérer toutes les géométries
possibles qu’elle peut tracer au cours du temps.
Elle peut suivre une certaine trajectoire,
vibrer d’une certaine façon,
mais également se dédoubler,
ce quirevient à émettre une particule,
ou se recombiner,
ce qui revientà réabsorber la particule,
formant une géométrie avec un trou.
En comptabilisant toutes les géométries possibles,
on inclut automatiquement lesinteractions en théorie des cordes.
Plus besoin de les ajouter manuellement.
De plus,
les interactions dans lemodèle standard étaient locales :
l’émission d’un photon,
parexemple, se faisait instantanément.
Mais en théorie des cordes
lesinteractions sont désormais continues,
la particule n’est pas émise
instantanément, mais progressivement.
Ceci permet d’éviter les valeurs
infinies et absurdes qu’on obtenait
lorsqu’on tentait d’inclure legraviton dans le modèle standard.
Ainsi, la théorie des cordes
prédit, non seulement l’existence du graviton,
mais elle nous permet également
de comprendre la façondont il interagit avec les autres particules,
et donc de décrire la gravité quantique.
Jusqu’ici, la théorie semble très prometteuse.
Elle explique pourquoi il existedifférents types de particules,
elle prédit qu’elles peuvent interagir,
et elle inclut une descriptionquantique de la gravité.
Mais malheureusement à ce stade
lemodèle présente… trois problèmes.
Premier problème :
toutes les cordesse comportent comme des bosons,
comme le photon ou le graviton.
Dans la réalité, il existe une autre
catégorie de particules :
les fermions, comme les électrons ou les quarks,
mais pour l'instant, notremodèle n'en prédit aucun.
Deuxième problème : l’une des particules
préditespar la théorie est ce qu’on appelle un “tachyon”.
Sa masse semble être
un nombre imaginaire,la racine carrée d'un nombre négatif.
Il s’agit d’une absurdité,
c’est unproblème mathématique qu’il faut éliminer.
Enfin, troisième problème :
notreespace-temps possède quatre dimensions :
trois dimensions d'espace, et une de temps,
mais cette théorie
ne semble fonctionnerque dans un univers à 26 dimensions.
A ce stade,
la théorie des cordes sembletrès loin de décrire notre univers...
Pour remédier à ces problèmes,
on vapousser la théorie un peu plus loin.
Afin d'iinclure les fermions dans notre modèle,
l’idée est d’ajouter des “spineurs” sur les cordes.
C’est l’ingrédient mathématique
qui permettait déjà de décrire les fermions dans le modèle standard.
Ce seul ajout, ajouter des spineurs sur les cordes,
permet de régler deux problèmes :
le modèle prédit maintenant l’existence de fermions,
et il ne prédit plus l’existence du tachyon,
la particule qui posait problème.
Cette théorie plus complète est baptisée théorie des “supercordes”.
En effet, maintenant que l’on a ajouté des spineurs,
la théorie présente une symétrie
fondamentale entre les fermions et les bosons.
D’une certaine façon,
elle prédit qu’il y aurait autant de bosons que de fermions :
c’est ce qu’on appelle la supersymétrie.
Qu’en est-il du troisième problème ?
Avant d’inclure la supersymétrie,
les mathématiques requéraient un univers à 26 dimensions.
Désormais,
la théorie des supercordes requiert un univers à 10 dimensions:
9 d’espace, et 1 de temps.
Malheureusement, ce troisième problème n’est pas réglé,
encore une fois la théorie ne semble pas coller à notre univers
qui possède seulement 4 dimensions.
Pourtant, jusqu’ici, le modèle semblait très prometteur.
Faut-il l’abandonner pour autant ?
Si elles existent, où seraient ces 6 dimensions manquantes ?
Une possibilité est que notre univers
nesoit qu’une tranche tri-dimensionnelle
d’un super-univers plus vaste, à 9dimensions
Une autre possibilité serait
que les 6 dimensions qu’on n’observepas
sont recroquevillées sur elles-mêmes...
Pour comprendre,
imaginons unefourmi qui se déplace sur une paille.
La paille a deux dimensions :
lafourmi peut marcher d'avant, en arrière,
et de gauche à droite sur le pourtour de lapaille.
Mais si l’on s’éloigne suffisamment,
le pourtour n’est plus perceptible.
On ne perçoitque l’une des deux dimensions.
La deuxième, celle qui fait le tour de la paille,
est toute petite, si bien qu’on ne la perçoit pas à cette échelle.
En théorie des cordes
on peut supposer unphénomène similaire :
notre univers aurait bien 9 dimensions d'espace,
mais 6 d’entreelles seraient de toutes petites
dimensions recroquevillées sur elles-mêmes,
si bienqu’on ne les voit pas à notre échelle.
Cette hypothèse peut paraître un peu douteuse.
Est-il raisonnable de supposer
l’existence de dimensions qu’on n’observe pas ?
Mais il se trouveque l’existence de dimensions
supplémentaires est une question très intéressante
qui proposedes phénomènes que l’on pourrait observer.
Par exemple, on peut imaginer
une particule sansmasse qui se déplace à la vitesse de la lumière,
mais en partie à l’intérieur d’unedimension compacte.
De notre point de vue, on ne perçoit pas cette dimension,
et parconséquent la particule nous semble plus lente,
on n’observe qu’une partie de son mouvement total.
A notre échelle, elle semble ralentie,
comme si elle possédait... une masse.
L’idée de dimensions compactes
supplémentaires propose ainsi un mécanisme plutôt simple
par lequel certaines particules
pourraient se manifester avec une masse très importante.
Cela dit, à l’heure actuelle,
ellesnécessiteraient beaucoup trop d’énergie
pour qu’on puisse les créer dans nos accélérateurs de particules
et vérifier si elles existent ou non.
La présence de ces 6 dimensions
supplémentairesen théorie des cordes
autorise également une gamme
beaucoup plus variée de modes de vibration,
etdonc, indirectement,
une plus grande diversité de particules possibles.
De plus, il existe une
multitude de façons différentes de recroqueviller 6 dimensions,
et chaque possibilité va prédire ununivers différent,
où les cordes peuvent
adopter des modes de vibration différents,
et donc secomporter comme des particules différentes.
En choisissant précisément
la façon dont sont compactifiées les 6 dimensions,
on peut régler notre description
pour qu’elle prédise les mêmes particules
que celles qu’on observe dans la réalité.
Cela dit, parmi la myriade de possibilités,
on ne sait pas encore dire pourquoi notre univers
contient les particules du modèle standard,
plutôt qu’une autre possibilité.
Selon certaines hypothèses encore spéculatives,
la géométrie de l’univers
aurait peut-être même varié au cours du temps,
passant d’une compactification à une autre,
et les lois de la physique auraient ainsi pu
changer pendant les premiers instants du Big Bang.
Pour conclure,
la théorie des cordes reste à ce jour une théorie spéculative,
très difficile à vérifier expérimentalement,
car les cordes seraient incroyablement minuscules.
Et qui n’est qu’une approche,
parmi tant d’autres, pour tenter d’aboutir à LA théorie ultime.
Mais il s’agit tout de même d’un des modèles les plus prometteurs,
dont les retombées ont largement dépassé son objectif original.
Les cordes permettent de décrire la gravité à l’échelle quantique,
et ouvrent des portes sur l’étude des trous noirs.
Elles ont permis de
développer de multiples pans des mathématiques,
et de mieux comprendre
certains aspects du modèle standard lui-même.
La théorie des cordes
propose même des candidats de particules hypothétiques,
comme les “axions”, pour potentiellement expliquer la matière noire.
Cela dit, il reste beaucoup de recherches à faire.
En particulier,
les aspects de la théorie des cordes qui sont les mieux compris
reposent sur l’hypothèse de la supersymétrie,
qui prédit l’existence de nouvelles particules,
qui pour l’instant ne sont pas détectées.
Il existe des compactifications qui pourraient
expliquer qu’on n’observe pas la supersymétrie,
mais elles restent très rares et encore très peu comprises.
Enfin, pour aller plus loin,
la théorie des supercordes existe en réalité en 5 versions différentes,
qui décrivent chacune des types d’univers différents.
Et on peut montrer mathématiquement que ces 5 théories
ne sont en réalité que des approximations d’un unique modèle,
encore plus complet,
une théorie décrivant un univers à 11 dimensions...
la théorie M.